The only thing that comes to mind specific to this group, I know your introduction was
about cancer, but I'm aligning and we can we can cover this tomorrow if you want that
to be the the version the venue, but in some of the materials that I've read from your
website, Align will my words probably not technical for you, but will change its frequency
over time. How often do we need to have a check back with you to make sure that the line protocols
we're using on our right are still the right concoction.
So a couple things will determine that. The biggest thing is how you're doing. So if
I have a line patient and they are stay there, they feel like they're staying stable or
they're slowly improving, then we may change the frequencies to up how much kill we got
in overnight program. So line programming for the right is extremely different than a cancer
program, because in a cancer program, we could put we're attempting to quote unquote kill
the cancer with the right frequencies. And the way a cancer cell is going to die with with the
right is going to stimulate a poptosis and that you will not get any quote unquote a hoax
cyber reaction from the cancer cells died. With Lyme disease, you're dealing not with your
normal cell, you're dealing with a bacteria. So we're killing that. Yeah, it's a grab
negative, which has a lipopolysaccharide in the cell membrane, and when you kill it, you're
going to liberate that lipopolysaccharide and that's going to stimulate an immune reaction,
that's going to cause difficulty in getting it out of the liver cell, you're going to have
that work cyber reaction. So we don't want to kill too fast. So if I speak to you or with any
live patient, they go, I'm doing really well, but I feel like I'm kind of plateaued. Then I'll say,
okay, then I'm going to tweak your program. We're going to add the amount of time that we're
doing. Kill. And we're going to push this a little bit harder. If the patient says, if the patient
says, so there's three things that can happen. The patient says, I'm doing horrible. Then I might
change the dual world. We're going to go slower. Number two, they say, I'm doing well, but I feel
like I'm plateaued. Then I'm going to change the dual world. We're going to go faster.
Number three is to say, I'm doing fantastic. Then I'm going to say, okay, well, it's not change anything.
Okay, so the frequency doesn't move. It's just the duration or dwell.
Well, the frequency may move because lots of times I'll get some, you know, what I add some was,
I maybe do some distance testing. I may add some empty bar. I may add some other
other co-infections that may help the person, too. So there's a with live, there's a lot of tweaking
that can be done. So whether a person's speed up or they're not doing well, we could do a lot of tweaking.
Okay, we'll probably talk more tomorrow than. Thank you.